uh colloquium so um
it's um uh we are starting with a
tutorial and
it's a great pleasure to introduce uh
zeph lander
who um i guess um
you know zeph got his uh phd in math
with uh
with juan jones of uh jones baldomir
fame
but then soon afterwards he saw the
light
and he moved to quantum computing where
he's done
you know fabulous work in this in this
area of
you know hamiltonian complexity and uh
he brings his uh
his expertise in operator algebras to
bear on it so i can't think of anybody
better to do this tutorial than
left so please
well i can think of plenty of people
better but that's i guess that's another
story
um let's see um
let me try to share my screen
see if that works
how are we doing on the share screen
does everybody see that
now i have to sort of
is that good
so let's see so yeah so i'm gonna um i'm
the warm up actuary thai and i'm gonna
tell you a little bit about ground
states for local hamiltonians um
uh starting from pretty basic stuff uh
hopefully
um let's see this i'm gonna sort of
break it down into two
pieces i'm going to sort of uh tell you
what ground states of local hamiltonians
are and motivate them
as a problem from several different
directions from physics and
computer science and math and then i'm
going to spend the second half of the
tutorial
talking about tensor networks which is a
framework that has
become extremely useful and sort of
looking at
ground states and studying their
properties so
and hopefully when we're done with that
you guys will all be ready to go with
the tie so
let's start from somewhere um so
the starting point is is sort of many
body physics right and so a picture in
this side
are lined up let's imagine these are
particles that are in a
square lattice but they can be anywhere
and the idea is that
as we're modeling this stuff each
particle represents a d-dimensional
space
and then the system as a whole
if it has n particles is the tensor
product of these individual spaces
so you end up with your world view is a
underlying space h that's uh d
dimensions tensored n
times and that's the dimension of that
space is exponential and n is d to the n
and so when we start to talk about
systems and by what we mean
is a system ends up being described by
some state
in this space um
you end up talking about a vector in an
exponentially large space
um and on the one hand that exponential
space is a great value that's why we
sort of think quantum
computation has um various
properties that we want to sort of um
exploit
because it can kind of travel around
this exponentially large space
but it also becomes this sort of great
challenge for understanding many body
physics because
with this exponentially dimensioned
space we can't even
describe the generic vector in this
space right so it's an exponentially
sized space if i give you an exponential
number of coefficients i've described it
but you know you're going to have a hard
time doing anything with that
because you'll be waiting too long to
describe it so
all right so that's the challenge right
you've got this exponentially large
phase now all is not lost
um because we aren't worried about all
the points
in this exponentially large space we're
only uh
in sort of interested from physically
motivated questions or other questions
to
you know let's call them physically
relevant states
um and so there's this point of view
that people have sort of
it may be helpful to think about which
is sort of like maybe the ones that we
really care about are in some corner
of hilbert space of this large
dimensional hillbid space
and that corner is easily er described
and of course corner i've written it as
a corner we should be very careful to
say like a corner
we don't quite know what we mean by
corner but it's a helpful sort of image
to have right that they're all sort of
someplace and we can we can work with
them without having to deal with
everything else that's around
okay and so the challenge is can we have
you know can we develop a better
understanding
of these states that are physically
relevant and
you know here are some basic questions
that that corresponds to is one do they
have some
special structure right which allows us
to kind of look at them
and then but more importantly does that
structure
allow for some sort of meaningful short
description remember we have this
challenge that the generic state does
not and we're looking at it in the
framework of just as an entry in the
tensor product space it does not and but
even more importantly is like if that
structure doesn't allow us to compute
anything we're kind of a little bit
stuck so we want
we want also that that structure somehow
allows us to compute something
okay so what are the physically relevant
space states that we're talking about
um well um today we're going to be
talking about ground states of local
hamiltonians so
that's a bunch of words and let me start
with what a local hamiltonian is
so remember we have this underlying
space which is a tensor product space
and then we're going to imagine that we
have a whole bunch of
local terms now what is a local term
well in this case
a local term is an operator that acts on
just
a few of these particles at a time in
the drawing we have that they act on
just two of the particles
um and what does that mean it means it's
a operator that
uh acts on the tensor product of two
copies of the d-dimensional space
and acts as the identity on the
remaining copies right so that's what i
mean by a local term
and i'm going to say that well that
local term should be self-adjoint it
should be a self-a joint operator
right um okay and then
my hamiltonian is going to be an
operator
that's a sum of these local terms so
it's going to be not just
any operator on the space but an
operator on the space that's given by
adding up a bunch of local terms and
usually when we think about this
we think about the local terms having
bounded by some constant norm the
individual terms so with
if it's convenient for you you can think
about them as
norm less than operator norm less than
or equal to one operators
and for most of the things if you're
sort of feeling already
hazy about what that means you can
picture them to be projections that
they're
there's most of the structure is
captured by that um
picture at least for the kinds of things
that i'm going to be talking about
okay so now we have this operator h
that's called a a local hamiltonian it's
a sum of local terms
and what we are interested in that's an
operator on the space remember we're
interested in
elements of the space and what we end up
being most interested in
for a lot of questions is the ground
state which
what's called the ground state of this
uh local hamiltonian which really means
it's all it means is it's the smallest
eigenvector of the local hamilton
okay so it's a vector in this
dimensional space and it's the smallest
eigen corresponds to the smallest
eigenvector
and ground states come from a physically
motivated point of view
which is the motivation is we can get an
approximate physics
physical model by lining up these
particles encoding the physics by local
interactions or first order
approximations by local interactions
and then if we consider these um spaces
in uh we consider this sort of system in
low temperature
things are going to move towards this
lowest eigenvector
and so that's where we're now so that's
the motivation for
why we're interested in ground states of
local hamiltonians because we sort of
feel like they describe something
capture something about the physics of
low temperatures
right so this is uh yeah i guess there
should be some mechanism for somebody to
pass on questions if people have
questions of course
please do um i think there are
moderators who can
jump in and i like it when people jump
in so um
okay so that's uh that's the objects
we're going to be studying
now i've described them from a physics
point of view
but there's a very natural computer
science point of view to think about
them
um and that is that there's a
fundamental connection between local
hamiltonians which i just described
and constraint satisfaction problems and
in in a very real sense
um local hamiltonians are the
non-communitive analog of constraint
satisfaction problems and i think it's
worth
going through that connection
to understand why it is that uh
computer science has had the effect that
it's had and brought a lot to bear on
these problems because there's sort of a
lot there's a lens coming from
computer science that um is not a
natural lens from the physics point of
view
or not as natural okay so what's a
constraint satisfaction problem well
i'll give you um well we'll do this by
example so that we can sort of get this
through
um so there's a problem of three color
abilities so that's a problem where you
get a map of some sort which i've tried
to describe there a bunch of countries
and you'd like to color the countries in
different colors
and you want them so that all the
boundaries are clear by having different
colors on
anything that shares a boundary and the
question is what graphs
are three colorable which means if i use
only three colors
um can i successfully color color this
graph
completely or will i run into trouble
where i'm sort of forced to use two
the same color on two neighboring
countries
so how do i sort of think about that and
sort of translate that problem into
something well i'm going to plop down
a dot on each country and i'm going to
allow that dot to take on three values
which is the three different colors
that i'm sort of imagining and
then what am i going to do i'm going to
say what's my constraint well my
constraint is that if they share a
boundary
right they can't have the same color so
i'm going to draw a line connecting any
two
dots that share a boundary and i think
of that line as composing the same
constraint each time which is hey
whatever color you've got on the one dot
you can't have on the other dot
everything's allowable as long as the
two colors are different
okay so each edge can edge encodes the
constraints and then
i'm interested in assignments that
satisfy as many constraints as possible
so if you think about what that means is
i want as an assignment and then i want
to count up how many of these
constraints
are violated and
this type of problem and and
the world in that this problem lives in
in computer science
is essentially the heart of complexity
theory right it's solving classifying
understanding the structure of the
solutions of these types of problems
is what computer science complexity
theory
thinks about all right so now what's the
connection between i've deliberately
drawn the blue as dots and
blue as particles to be the same things
and the edges to be the same things as
what i was
calling local hamiltonian terms and so
let's see that correspondence
so here i have on the left side
become the uh computer science world
where you should think of the three
colorable problem and on the right
side the local hamiltonian version and
so here i've got my graph
and the number of colors on the left
side
is corresponding to the dimension of the
particles on the right side
and then the local constraint on the
left side let's imagine it on the right
side and ask what did it look like
on the right side right so it was a
constraint that insisted that a color on
between the two colors you had them
different and so what that corresponds
to if i try to write down that as a
local hamiltonian
it becomes a diagonal operator
in the standard basis where the basis i
was using was the basis that
corresponded to different colors so
i can see the setup here as being the
constraint satisfaction problem
has local constraints that are diagonal
if we think of it as a local hamiltonian
problem
okay and so then what does the
assignment that violates the fewest
constraints correspond to
that's for the for the three colorable
problem
that corresponds to the lowest eigen
value or the sorry the assignment
corresponds to the lowest eigenvector
and the lowest eigenvalue corresponds to
the least number of constraints that are
violated by this solution
right so hopefully you sort of
understand this connection and so that
from a
computer science point of view local
hamiltonians
are just the non-community of
generalization of
constraint satisfaction problems why
non-commutative because if everything's
in the diagonal basis
as they were on the left side they all
commute but
in general the hi local terms that act
and share
that share particles to act on may not
commute
and that's really where the um sort of
complexity comes from of the of the
quantum systems
okay all right so
i've set up this situation so there are
two you know
there are two venue views of how we can
um
look at local hamiltonians
ground states of local hamiltonians one
is the generalization of constrained
satisfaction problems
the other as the solutions to physical
questions of interest
and i'll remind you what our goal in
this whole process is is that now that
we have this target
of these these
vectors in this high dimensional space
we want to understand
again do they have any special structure
and does that structure allow for
meaningful short descriptions
and does that structure allow for to
compute various properties
and so those are some good questions and
the answer there's been sort of a lot of
progress i would say in the last 30
years
in progress is in both directions
progress is where some of the answers
are yes and
progress is for other quests for other
problems where the answer is no so this
ends up being sort of a classification
type
question right there they're physical uh
models that are of particular interest
where the his are a particular form
and we can hope to maybe say something
special about those we can also
hope to say something if we if we allow
as much generality as possible maybe we
can sort of
uh say something no and about that there
aren't
there can't be short descriptions um and
that's sort of where
progress has come and it's combined
ideas from physics computer science and
mathematics and i think a tai will touch
on
you know in the process of giving the
talk that he gives you'll see
the sort of entryway of all these
different uh pieces and points of view
um so what i want to do that's sort of
the first half of what i wanted to talk
about
and the second half that i wanted to
talk about was um
a sort of a very useful framework for
looking at these questions and in my
bias point of view in a lot of questions
for
for quantum computation um certainly has
helped me a lot
um and that's a point of view that
is that i'm interested in an object
called
tensor networks um so
i'm gonna spend some time on tensor
networks and this is actually the time
when um i know when it's a large talk
one is intimidating if one gets lost and
confused but
um i would say this is the time to ask
questions because um not not now but as
i go through the tensor network
portion of the talk um because it's
uh it really is meant for people in part
for people who may not have seen this
stuff before
and um as long as if you can hang on and
i'm not going to go that fast but if you
can hang on
you get a feel for things that will be
sort of even tap into intuition already
that will be helpful for
for the next talk um and for just in
general
so okay so my joint of view of tensor
networks is that there is a powerful
it's a powerful sort of visual lens on
things it gives me intuition it tells
it explains why a lot of things are true
but you know
there are other people who have points
of view too um
and you know the young people are
talking about it and and
so i'll sort of just highlight a few of
them
which is the first is that tensor
networks when you're done they give you
a geometric view of linear algebra
as george seems to have discovered and
that can be very uh helpful because
linear algebra sort of when you start to
write it down especially with complex
systems
you end up with a lot of notation um and
it's very hard sometimes to see what's
going on and
um um this is sort of gives you a very
intuitive picture of what's going on
it's accurate it's a one-to-one
correspondence with what's going on
um they are really once you they really
are useful in a lot of different
contexts
and um i guess um yeah so
an example of something that um is very
easily seen
is that for those of you who know these
words is that
for instance this is just an example
that the schmidt decomposition and
singular
value decomposition are the same thing
right they're
they're certainly not thought of as the
same thing or described initially as the
same thing but they are the same thing
and it's um okay and if you're sort of
inspired um there's a full tutorial
i gave a talk at simon's a while ago a
bootcamp talk and um
that might be a place for you to uh
painlessly go through this and have some
of the joys of discovering some of the
pieces
yourself um okay so let me tell you what
cancer networks are
um so i'm gonna start by describing
tensors now some of you
or most of many of you have an idea of
tensors because you've learned them in
different forms
usually when i describe this form it's
not what people think of as tensors
but but this is how i think of tensors
so here's what i think of a tensor as
it's an object which i've drawn on the
screen there
and what are the features of that object
oh actually can you see my cursor
is that is that do you see the arrow
okay all right
so um what it what it is
um is it there's a dot in the middle
that's labeled there's here's a
vertex labeled by m and then there's
some number of legs coming out of it in
this case that there are five
and we'll call this a five tensor okay
so it's just right now it's just a
visual object and let me tell you what
this visual
object let me tell you the components of
the visual object so the first
components is that the edges
come with a possible
uh set of labels that you can use on
them let's in this case there are k
possible labels you can label each of
the edges by k possible different things
and when you've labeled all the edges by
some element
m will spit out a number okay so here's
an example down here
m we've labeled the first edge by one
the second by three the third by one the
fourth by two this two
by five and m encodes m now once
everything's labeled it spits it tells
you what number it has which is 2.7
so this is somehow some encoding of some
k to the number of edges set of numbers
and they're sort of indexed in this way
okay so that's what a tensor is
and now i'm going to tell you things
that the two basic operations that i'm
going to allow
to you to do when you have two tensors
which will form
a new tensor so here's the first
operation that i want you to do um let's
see somebody should say if they
i can blow this up if um
if need be there's a there's a basic
realization that i came to at two in the
morning which
was clearly an observation i should have
come to him way before that which was
that an eight and a half
by 11 sheet of paper vertically is not
the basic dimensions of a slide so
things are a lot smaller than they
i had anticipated that they would be but
anyway so
here is i'm going to give you two
operations we can do with tensors so i
have two different tensors now remember
the tensors don't have to have the same
number of legs coming out of them
different tensors can have different
so the first is a product and so here
i've written down
a example of a product so i have one
tensor m
that's a six tensor and a second tensor
n which is a three tensor
and i'm gonna lay them down side by side
and i'm gonna tell you
how to think of them as a new tensor
which is a nine tensor and i'll tell you
how to think about it
and the way to the easiest way to think
about it this is imagine that somebody
gives you
some they they take you very far away
from this picture
which i guess by making this picture
small i have but imagine you can't see
it very well
and so you don't really see the in the
intricate structure you just see the
legs shooting out of this tensor and so
you imagine that you can't really see
inside the red dotted lines so
we just think of that as a single node
and then all kinds of nine edges coming
out of that node
and so now all i have to tell you if i'm
going to think about it that way is i'm
going to have to tell you if you label
the nine edges coming out of that load
node how should you decide what the
value that tensor will have
and the value you should have so if you
label all these nine edges
well then if you were able to look
inside you'd see that m
is fully labeled and n is fully labeled
and the label that you should want to
spit out is the product of the label
that m would spit out according to its
labeling and
an n is is for its labeling okay so
that's the product that's the product of
two tensors you've gotten another tensor
and the second operation is a little
more involved but not too much
i've again used the same m and n uh
somehow i lost the value of m
here but what's different about this one
is i've connected one of the free legs
of
m to one of the free legs of n that's
what's drawn here by this line
and now if i look from far away i see
seven free edges right because two of
the edges were joined together so it's
no they're no longer free edges
and so now i want to interpret this as a
seven tensor
and so let me try to do the same thing
i've done before i'm gonna label the
outside guys
label all those outside guys now if i
look at the individual tensors
there's one edge from each of the two
tensors that's that is not labeled at
the moment
and they it's the one they share and
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
cycle through all the possible labels of
that
that edge so first i label it by one and
as soon as i've labeled that edge by one
it labels both
n side by one and m side by one
and now each m and n are fully labeled
and i can take their product as i did
before
so when i put the value 1 here it spits
out a product and when i put the value 2
it spits out a product
and the value that i'm going to assign
to the whole thing is the sum
of those products as i cycle through all
the possible labelings of this
sealed edge right so that's what i've
written down here the layer you label
all external edges and you sum
over all possible labeling of the
internal edge and then what you sum is
the product of the two
tensors all right so
that is so now we've got two ways to
take tensors and make more tensors out
of them
right well i can lay them both down on
the screen um
however i want that's the product and i
can start to join
edges of them and i of course i can join
more than one edge if i follow the
sequence each time
sequentially okay
so
now let's back up now i have i've
already said how to operate on
how how operations can do we can sort of
construct some operations on tensors but
let's back up and sort of
understand how i want to think about the
tensor because i want to think about it
flexibly in multiple ways
right so here's the first way i want to
think about the tensor i want to think
about the tensor as a vector
and so let me tell you how i'm going to
do that so first i want to tell you the
space
that i'm going to think of it as a
vector in and the space i'm going to
think of it as a vector in is
remember that each of these edges had a
number of labels that i could give it
and i'd say i called that labels that
there were k different labels
so i'm going to think of this vector
it's going to land in the space that's a
dimension
um let's call v a k
dimensional space it's going to land in
the space that's
tensor product of three copies of v one
for each edge that's out there
right so m is gonna i'm gonna think of m
as a vector
in the tensor product three of v three
times and how am i gonna think of it as
a vector
well i'm going to think of the labels as
basis elements
right in an orthogonal basis of my
choice a fixed orthogonal basis of my
choice
so i've written e1 through ek if you're
used to physics notation you could sort
of say
cat 0 through cat i guess k
minus 1 to make sure that there are k of
them right so you can think of it either
way
and the vector that i get is going to be
the coefficient
in front of e i tensor e j tensor e k
is going to just be the number that spit
out if i labeled the first
edge by e i the second edge by e j and
this or
i and the second edge by j and the third
edge by k
so again i now see that m i'm going to
view
m as a vector where m's
values are giving coefficients in this
in in
a standard basis of a tensor product of
three copies of this of a standard
fixed basis so that's my first view
of m as a vector but i can also view m
as a linear map and let me show you one
example of that linear map
and then i'm going to sort of you'll be
able to see how there are many linear
maps that i'm going to show
so i'm going to view it as a map and
there's a typo right here this
um i guess it's not a typo but a script
or something
um this should be a two right so there
should be one copy of v
here and only two copies of v here not
three and i'm going to think of it as a
map
from this edge
to these two edges and that's what's
going to scar this edge is going to
correspond to this
v and these two edges are going to
correspond to the tensor product of two
copies of v
so let me tell you how to do that well
if i'm going to tell you a linear map
all i have to do is tell you how to
evaluate it
on a basis right so let me tell you how
to evaluate
this linear map from here to there on a
basis
of this space and so here's how i do it
i'm going to tell you how m takes e i so
if i
if i'm acting on e i i imagine that my
first
edge is labeled by i okay
and if it's labeled by i it's going to
be mapped to
a vector in v tensor v
and its coefficient in the j k direction
in e j tensor e k is going to be just
the coefficient i would get by labeling
this edge by j and this edge by k
so m of e i ends up being the sum of m i
j
k e j tensor e k where m i j
k is my notation for label the
corresponding edges by i j
and k and tell me what the number m that
you spit out is
now for people who are used to tensor
networks from
physics and tensors from physics there's
some conjugation that tends to be
introduced called contravariant
covariant these kinds of things
this we are not doing any of that in
this picture we are not
uh having directionality to this thing
this is a well-defined structure as is
and
this is where it will deviate a little
bit from the there'll be some complex
conjugates that you
don't deal with okay so
the point here being is that the same
object
can be viewed as a vector it can also be
viewed as a map from here to these two
copies
it can also be viewed as a map from any
we can
take the edges of a of a tensor
divide them into two groups and see it
as a map from the tensor product of
copies of the edges on the one group to
the tensor product
copies of the edge of the other group
and those are all at the same time so
they can't
they they they encode all these things
at the same time
all right so all right i've set up this
structure now why is this structure
even worth paying any attention to well
because
in a very nice way it encodes a lot of
nice things and so i'm going to give you
the summary of some of the nice things
that it codes
to just to motivate sort of to get a
feel and to motivate
so on the top here i've drawn three
pictures that i'm going to go through
um the first picture is
just all right this is just a tensor
right this is just a tensor
two tensors joined together they each
were one tensors to start they only had
one leg coming out
and what you should so to remind you
when an edge is together you sum over
possible labelings of the edge of the
one thing with that label of the edge
times the other thing with that label of
the edge
and if you spend a small bit of time on
that you'll realize that this is the
inner product of
m with n the summation of m i
and i and so when you see this like if i
interpret m as a vector and
n as a vector i get the inner product of
m and n
and again we can sort of worry about do
we need inner product we mean
do we conjugate the second variable we
don't let's not worry about that right
now let's just imagine everything was
real
um and so it's a summation of m i n i
okay so this picture is in a product so
when i see it i should think inner
product
what about this picture right so this
picture
i can whereas over here i interpreted m
as a vector and n as a vector here i'm
going to interpret
a as a linear map from this top space to
the second space
and i'm going to consider b to be a
linear map from this space
to this space and this picture ends up
being composition
or matrix product right and so if i
write down if i look at this
tensor and i sort of get vague and put a
dotted line around here it's a new
tensor
with one one leg up here and one leg
down there
and if i think of it as a map from here
to here it's
the map that's the composition of these
two maps
the third picture that i want to just
sort of highlight is
here's a picture we haven't seen before
which is the two edges of
a a we had two edges coming out of it
and here we've joined them up
now if i interpret a as a map from the
left
from the top edge to the bottom edge and
what does this
thing return well it returns it's i sum
over possible labelings of this edge
which is i and i get a
i i if i thought of a as a matrix with
entries
i j i get the sum of a i i which is the
trace of a
so looping over the trace of a i didn't
go through the
process of summing over k here but
if you did you'd say you know the value
for this big tensor at i
and j is the sum over k of a i k times
b k j which is exactly you would
recognize matrix product
okay all right so anyway these pictures
have some nice meanings to them
and let me just sort of highlight
give you a flavor for the kinds of
things that happen so now if i ask you
we all know trace of a b
is the same as trace of b a and if i
asked you to prove it
you probably would do so very
successfully
and what you would do is you'd sort of
write a as
uh it's individual code you'd sort of uh
expand a and as a matrix you'd expand b
as a matrix and
and you'd sort of sum over various
things and that's what would happen
and you do this calculation and you
check the left side as the right side
and switch
switch thumbs around and you'd be all
set well let me show you the proof
in the picture world of tensor networks
the picture world is as follows here is
trace of a b
right i've written a times b and i've
traced it
okay so now i'm just going to take a and
i'm going to just pull it up
and i'm not really doing anything i just
sort of stretch the string a little bit
so now a is on its side and then i
stretch the string a little bit so now
a's upside down over here
and i stretched it a little bit more and
it is over here and i bring it back down
and it is over here all right i haven't
changed the tensor network that's
absolutely clear right nothing has
changed i've just been stretching
strings
and what is this this is b times a
and then taking the trace of it so this
is a proof that trace of a b equals
trace of b a
it didn't involve writing down any sums
switching indices
anything like that okay so this is the
kind of thing
that maybe exemplifies why tensor
networks
can be a really valuable tool because
visually it gives you something that
otherwise you might have gotten lost in
notation now you know the example is a
little bit
let's say simple but that
simplicity should not you should not
take that simplicity for granted because
that
there's plenty more complicated things
that it sheds light on
okay so what's a tensor network i've
talked about tensors and combining a
tensor network
is just a network of tensors put
together with these products and these
uh
um and these uh contraction rules
so here's an example one and uh uh you
know just an example
of a seven tensor and i guess i just
wanted to make sure it's clear
that these these joinings up do not have
to be linear sorry do not have to be
planar
they can be they don't have to exist in
the plane as you can see the connection
between e and c
we didn't have to do anything we can
just imagine them connected
um and the evaluation you know this may
be a little bit overwhelming
i can sort of think of it as being
formed in many different ways but just
to stress
no matter how you form it in terms of
cancering and contracting and whatever
you do
you end up with the same object which
really is it's
you end up summing over the internal
edges
the ones that are drawing two things
together of all possible labelings of
those
uh and then you take the products if you
label the outsides you take the product
of all the pieces that you get and you
sum
that's what you're evaluating okay all
right
so okay so why have i sort of spent this
amount of time on tensors
um and tensor networks is because they
i they provide in i think in hindsight
a very good framework for
a picture of
a framework for for looking at the
states that we're interested in
okay so the states that we're interested
remember are uh ground states of local
hamiltonians
and tensor networks or simple tensor
networks
in particular are good candidates and
seem to both
um be good candidates for this corner of
hilbert space that we were
talking about so let me sort of say a
little bit more um
so here's a proposal right for the
physically relevant states let's
imagine if we'd like or um hope
right that the physically relevant
states are described by nice tensor
networks
now what do i mean by nice well um not
sure
but here are some candidates for nice
that have worked out quite well
um so in one dimension right so if the
particles are lined up in a line
here's a tensor network
that's a very particular form right it's
just got a one node
up here for each of the particles one
edge coming down for each of the
particles
and neighboring particles are joined by
a line now i've no i've
i've drawn this line to be blue rather
than
the pencil color and the reason is that
back before
i never really said this but you can
imagine that this should be fine
is that when we were talking here i had
every edge had
k possible labels for them but you can
imagine that edges come in different
forms
and some of the edges could have k
possible labels other edges had l
possible
uh labels and as long as i always join
edges that have this
have the label set of the same type
this makes sense right i don't have to
have all things being the same
and that's the picture i have here i
have a different
number of labels for the blue than i do
have the black and so the the black
gets labeled by the dimension of the
local space that's d
for the d part the d dimensional space
of the local particle is
and the blue is something called that is
termed the bond dimension and i'll use
capital d
to say how many different labels you
could have of the blue spaces
and the idea is that if i can keep d
relatively small and relatively small
means either
constant or polynomial this is a
restriction on the kinds of states that
can be if i
allow d to get all the way up to
exponential i can describe any state
in the in the any vector in the vector
space
but if i restrict them to small maybe
this is a nice
playground of states to work in maybe
this is a nice corner
to be in right and these are have
special names they're called matrix
product states
and the 2d analog of these if the
particles were were
um um so so again maybe the imagery
is uh for for the 1d1 is think of it as
a cone
right it's sort of a comb it's connected
and the and the teeth of the comb are
coming down
and for the 2d and analogous if you can
sort of get this picture
now think of this as like a hair brush
right so the hair brush is
flat uh and this bristles are coming out
towards you
and the bristles are the free edges
which correspond one to each particle on
a
2d lattice and in between they're
connected by these blue lines
which are internal edges to our tensor
network these are called projected
entangled pair states
and there are other possible candidates
for nice tensor networks
where we can do something but this
though and i'll mention them down here
they're mirrors and tree tensor networks
but let's just stick with these two for
the moment
and so let's see why they're nice and
sort of spend a moment or two on why
they're nice
well the first reason why they're nice
is that they have a short description
right if i describe the individual
tensors each of which are
a small object i just a small array of
numbers they actually
you know that's enough to describe this
whole vector in this big dimensional
space
right we sort of have this way of
combining these that information
together in different ways to
to get the various coefficients it also
supports
addition in the following sense if i
take two tensors
with low bond dimension and when i add
them up
it turns out that i can express it as a
new tensor with
not as low a double dimension but the
bond dimensions just add
all right so at a minimum i can sort of
do that as a structural thing so it's
sort of a
structure that allows some amount of
adding together not
not arbitrary because eventually you get
the bond dimension to be too big
and it also supports the application of
local operators so
here i'm imagining i have a vector v
which i've expressed as a matrix product
state
and an operator a that's local it's just
going to act on these two particles
and i haven't sort of covered this but
the part the
the operator itself can be expressed as
a tensor with some amount of
bond between the two like this and so
when i package these together it's just
a matter of
applying again because of my linear
algebra to apply
a matrix to a vector i just stick these
things together
and the result is that my bond between
this particle and this particle may grow
but it's bounded by how much it can grow
so that's i've said this it can
be repackaged as a new matrix product
state
and the growth of the bond is is bounded
by the product
of the bonds in the two previous ones
and so this allows us to some amount of
sort of to play in that space and work
in that space at least for a while if we
can kind of control the bonds and how
they're growing
and the final thing that is really the
powerful one is that in 1d
computation is tractable remember that
was one of our goals was an expression
of things where we could actually do
something
and i want to sort of highlight that the
inner product of
v with w right that's this
picture here now i want to
argue that this picture we can compute
even though we couldn't actually sort of
describe the individual vectors because
they were an exponential number of terms
i can do this calculation without
crossing that exponential boundary and
the way i do that is a very clever thing
which is
i take a view of this tensor as formed
not as these two individual tensors
interproducted together but as a
different sequence and let me try to
tell you what that sequence is i imagine
a cut here
and on the left of the cut i think of it
as a vector
and that vector sits in the blue space
tensor together twice
and then i imagine a cut here and i
think of what's in between that
and that's a lin if i think of it as
acting from left to right
it's a linear operator from a d squared
dimensional space to another d squared
dimensional space
and combined with this one it's just the
application of that linear operator to
that vector
and so that's a calculation that i'm
doing on a d squared dimensional space
that's a small space
and i can see in sequence reinterpret
this tensor as this
product that goes from left to right
always sitting on a d squared
dimensional
space i have to do it n times but that's
fine and so i've done my linear algebra
calculation which is the inner product
of v with w
without ever crossing this exponential
boundary i've just lived in a d squared
dimensional space and done n
multiplications in that space
all right so that's what makes 1d matrix
product state so powerful is the ability
to do linear algebra
by which i mean these inner products
okay so
i have this formulation about to wrap up
i have this formulation
right which is that uh what if right
i started with what if this is the right
playground to use
right what if this is the right
playground for these states to be
these ground states well let me tell you
one
simpler consequence i mean maybe i can't
get this whole structure but what would
have to be true
and that's something called an area law
and so let me just briefly tell you what
that means is you imagine
splitting your hilbert space into two
pieces a left side and a right side in
one dimension and
in two dimensions right so imagine
splitting your space into two particles
on the left particles on the right
particles on the left particles on the
right and you ask yourself for the state
that you're talking about
how many product terms do you need right
so here i've written it in
in language right so if a hilbert space
is a tensor product of two spaces the
left space and the right spaces
how big a sum do i need if i want to
write it as a sum of terms v i v
i sitting in the left space and wi
sitting in the right space
now this number is called the
entanglement rank
of a of this vector across this cut the
minimal number that this can be
and let's take a look in this picture
what this number looks like so in the 1d
case this number looks like it can't be
any bigger than d
right because the blue bound line is d
so if i sum
over the d labels of this each time i
label this i get a vector on the left
and a vector on the right
and for this one uh if as soon as i
label
all these guys which are their n guys
each with d possible capital d possible
labels each as i labeled those guys
i end up with something on the left and
something on the right so in one d
this corresponds to d things d that my
question mark is d
terms and the other it's d to the n
and in both i can see this as d
to the size of the boundary of the cut
and that's what an area law says and
area law says that
if i cut the system into two the number
of terms i need as products of left and
right
scales like d to the boundary now
uh there are various other more
complicated ways or more
refined ways to talk about this namely
that you talk about it as
not that not the not the entanglement
rank that scales that way
but the entanglement entropy which i've
carefully avoided using because i find
it a little bit
daunting but if in terms of the entangle
meant entropy it ends up being that the
entanglement entropy
is no more than the then the boundary of
uh the the size of the boundary of the
cut or order the boundary of the cut
um and i should just remark that that
that that amount
a generic a generic vector will have
not will have much more um this the the
number of terms you'll need is much more
a generic vector of the amount of terms
you'll need will be the dimension of the
smaller of the two spaces on the left
and the right
here we're just picking up the dimension
of the boundary and that's what's in
in is in an area along
and in particular in the you know the
entanglement rank
or the log of the entanglement ramp is
an upper bound for the entanglement
entry
right and uh that's it i'm sorry to run
a couple minutes over
but um yeah
thanks for listening and thanks for your
attention
uh great uh thanks for a really
beautiful talk um
uh let's see um
um maybe we could see if there's
this um there's a a quick question
before we move on to the the colloquium
so there are several questions and we
have all been answering here uh
so i mean there were a lot of questions
i don't think there's any left
let's see that's good i suppose yeah i
think it was
the best thing a lot of questions
they've all been answered that's sort of
the best
well that was a particularly clear talk
i think um
thanks thank you
okay so um